hello guys and welcome to another
commentary video so we've been given a
new look at doctor strange yet again so
the first image here is an image we have
seen previously however that was through
a magazine and the image now has been
released in full hd so this image is of
doctor strange and america chavez which
it seems like they could be in a sanctum
of sanctorum but i'm gonna guess this
scene is set after the scene they share
in the street because i kind of feel the
scene of them in the street is the first
time they met each other while we're on
the topic of the street scene we have a
new image from that scene of doctor
strange casting the spell of a mystical
blade we've seen him do this in a
trailer but this is from a different
angle that we haven't seen before it's a
really cool looking scene i gotta say
the cgi is looking wonderful moving on
we have some promotional art release for
multiverse of madness in this art we
have doctor strange wong america chavez
and wonder we can also see more of
wanda's new outfit in this promotional
art and i gotta say i'm really really
digging her new outfit it's looking
really good and i'm curious to see what
type of roles these characters will play
in the movie and lastly we have a quote
from the wizard himself doctor strange
benedict cumberbatch he says it's going
to be a completely mind-bended thrilling
ride it really is the title speaks from
an experience of watching it i believe
and certainly of making it there was a
lot of madness a lot of multiverse and a
lot of doctor strange and the fact that
he has mentioned there will be a lot of
multiverse this just further cements
that there's going to be a lot of cameos
and a lot of crazy stuff happening in
this film so i couldn't be more excited
but what do you guys think tell me in
the comment section below if you haven't
already please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching